honte à vous écrit un parent sur la page
facebook de l'association canadienne des
allergies ou le hashtag nat loving it a
rapidement commencé à se répandre
triste jour bye bye nique dans l'aude
après 22 ans en s'appuyant sur vos
politiques de sécurité et qu'il ya
d'autres consommateurs entraîné des
centaines de commentaires
marie-josée bétey fondatrice et
rédactrice en chef du site web déjouer
les énergies forte demande pour nos
produits dit noah est nouveau mais ghana
j'étais vraiment l'endroit où plusieurs
personnes allergiques
on est tous au courant que ses côtés la
haute gastronomie
mais pour plusieurs familles c'était
extrêmement pratique
m yves bastien représente les intérêts
de l'association des restaurateurs du
québec
le restaurateur au défi de mettre à
l'abri de poursuites éventuelles
la responsable est le nouveau a fait du
bouclier de voir un film en appui à
l'offre son régime
sanofi et problème de fierté jusqu'à
présent avec darnaud était l'une des
rares chaînes de restauration rapide au
pays à porter une attention particulière
à la contamination croisée entre ces
aliments et les produits allergènes
comme les noix ou les arachides quoi n'a
rien d'un vézina mehr québécoise de deux
enfants en bas âge elle est sur le qui
vive
à chaque fois qu'il est question
d'arachides ou de noix j'allais chez ma
voisine qui a un enfant du même âge
assurer que ma voiture était pas loin
c'est tout était en fonctions que je
puisse partir métal hôpital psy à une
réaction parce que son frère est un
berger qui a plus de chances qu'elle le
devienne dans le pire des cas l'allergie
alimentaire en train ce qu'on appelle
l'anaphylaxie et les cas
d'hospitalisation pays augmente assez
rapidement à environ 14000 que prévu
environ coccinelles et wan et chercheuse
principale à l'institut canadien
d'information sur la santé complètement
changé on doit être un nouvel aliment à
notre bibi et donc moi quand ma fille
était d iliad
il fallait agir avec beaucoup de
précaution il ne peut pas traduire et
arraché deux vendus dans des aliments
plutôt si une exposition trop fréquentes
au menu rapide des chaînes de
restaurants sur le pouce et dangereuses
pour la santé
avec ou sans moi on confirmait plus tôt
ce mois-ci que l'absence totale
d'exposition ou noix et aux arachides et
dangereuse
l'institut national de la santé des
états unis recommande ainsi d'introduire
des arachides dès l'âge de 4 à 6 mois
pour les enfants à haut risque
d'allergie pour les enfants qui ne
souffrirait pas d'allergies alimentaires
en principe on recommande d'inclure les
arracher dans la diète à partir de l'âge
de 6 mois donc les pseudos originale de
2007 qui était à haut risque de
développer des allergies alimentaires
soit ceux qui avaient de l'examen
ferrara jeune âge où des jeunes allergie
aux le docteur philippe bégin et
allergologue à l'hôpital pour enfants
sainte-justine à montréal alors giflé
enfants alors on s'est rendu compte que
dès l'âge de 4 mois il y avait déjà plus
pour se désinfecter déjà allergiques aux
arachides
quand on introduisait lilly rush est
précoce et maintenant on prévenait le
développement de nouvelles allergies aux
arachides au cours des années
subséquentes
alors que d'un côté on avait 13 pour
scinder un frein qui développait des
nouvelles allergies aux arachides faut
tomber à zéro pour cent c'est en somme
un truck series williams
mais comme il y avait déjà un risque
d'allergie au moment d'être sauvée c'est
qu'il faut vraiment consulter son
allergologues son théâtre avant d'être
réduits relais
la cause du tu risques de réactions
d'acteurs moshi ben shushan était leur
golog au centre universitaire de santé
mcgill à montréal et on attend trop
longtemps on perde cette fenêtre
d'opportunité pour développer une
tolérance
alors aujourd'hui on dit que c'est mieux
de commencer plus tôt à quatre à six
mois
un reportage de radio canada
international